I wish I didn't have a call I'm a
Mexican brothers and sisters to get a
hue
Mexico City was one of those truly
special residences it was it was
unbelievable
I think it will go down in everyone's
memory bank as one of the most special
times in Metallica's history
you watch massive West goodies we have
about how many pages of storyboards this
is essentially the narrative it's every
single scene storyboarded with the
exception of the riot that's have to
come
gilsu bunch of guys with lookbook you
have the rider on a horse it's pretty
badass we also have the little man the
best have not had an opportunity to see
the little man quite yet Walken moly
we started the tour in Mexico City you
know the theory was basically how many
shows did Metallica need to play to both
warm themselves up warm up the stage
instruct the director or half the
director instruct us about what we
should do or what he should look for
because he's never shot Metallica before
I knew that we needed to be in one place
to work on the show for a long time we
needed to be somewhere where we could
work on the show not work on loading in
and out leading up to Mexico the show
wasn't ready no one knew if the Tesla
coil would fire no one knew if Doris
would fall no one knew if anything was
going to properly work despite couple of
weeks of production rehearsals in
California and the band being there and
there just wasn't enough time because
that is a gargantuan production this is
the largest indoor production in the
history of touring I'm going to start
killing people who tell me that 3d is
the complicated part of us the hard part
here is the size of this stage it begs
big profane words
what we did back to the internet days
was we had a lot of little incidents
happen fires here parent pyro going off
to the point of where the whole show
basically fell apart and so our
narrative on this tour such the same
thing I'm a spot-up and when the trust
Falls is supposed to be explosion I get
knocked out and follow the chair it's 40
feet up there so I'm on just cinder so
it decelerates just they don't kill
yourself but you look like you fall 45
doesn't hurt you butterflies coming cuz
you yeah cues coming up you gonna do it
uh-uh but did you know next time couple
times you do it get some lazier what's
so great about it throwing a live show
process it's still you just never know
what could happen
safety is paramount what we do is
extremely dangerous we're running the
destruction sequence Darius Sandman I
hear somebody say get the guitars and
then I see a plume of smoke but I start
running and I did not realize it but
it's not smoke it was oil
I work boxes covered covered by petal
balls company guitars the amp racks the
covered in one just going to soil pulled
it all out put oil dry down everywhere
I'm just leaning on this it's not really
something I know it is and we'll get
ready for the band in a couple of hours
we hope Peter are one of our managers
had a clear vision that the toilet was
gonna be great and call it a jour being
in a band 30 years you know having a
toilet come down at the end of your show
it's like really it was this too damn
clean before I had to get in there and
tag it with metal up your ass so at
least it gave it a little more of a
garage filled El Diablo gato
we're gonna have to match the crowd all
right yeah so let's try to kick ass too
all right
it was great man it was like driving a
new car that you've never driven you
stared at it for like weeks now I
haven't been able to like actually get
into it but tonight was the night we
were actually able to like get into the
vehicle and drive it and it was
fantastic
we've been playing in the middle of the
arena for the better part of twenty
years it's a lot of fun like 148 years
old you know every time you get up on
stage it's a lot of fun because that
fact you actually can climb up the
stairs you know is a minor miracle in
itself
there was there was a couple moments
with the pyro it was just so incredible
and powerful I was like are we sure that
this stuff is working correctly because
it's so scary this is such a powerful
feeling to know that you're surrounded
by all of this danger but it's working
in your direction it's working with you
to bring an amazing visual experience
for people watching it